Most people agree that this is the ugliest mammal in Africa.
Warthog mothers and their piglets often visit mudholes.
They're one of the only pigs active during the day,...
...so like the rhino, they need to protect their skin from the fierce sun.
And protection is part of the reason for that strange, disproportionate head.
It's rock-hard, a helmet that even a leopard's teeth can't penetrate.
But it has other uses, too.
The warthog's muzzle is shaped like a shovel...
...so it can turn over hard earth for tasty bulbs and roots,...
...but they often have to get down on their knees to support that heavy armored head.
No one would call warthogs handsome,...
...but to add injury to insult, this one's lost an eye,...
...probably escaping from a hungry lion.
Fortunately, warthogs are well-armed.
These tusks are formidable weapons.
The biggest ones ever seen were two feet long on the outside edge.
But it's the smaller, lower tusks that are the danger.
They can be very sharp, and they're the main weapon in attack.
And what about the warts that give these pigs their name?
Males have four.
Females, two.
They're not really warts, but protective pads of cartilage and gristle.
In battle, the strategically placed pads deflect thrusting tusks...
...away from soft parts of the face,...
...shielding the eyes and mouth.
For warthogs, an ugly snout can literally be a lifesaver.